дискусія про за ворону буркіні у
франції розварилася з нової сили і
кислота ви я беру спа вілли по інцидент
на одному з пляжів у ниць і
на цих кадрах ви дно їх поліцейський
підходить вечеря до в хусті тунець та штанах
хочемо он вона їх не вам овочі запасний
болі та знімаючи туніку з литого
поліцейський випуск та штрафну квитанцію
зерно спа ведена мізки за насильно
буркіні на пляжах блакитного vous би рідше
оштрафовано на 38 євро в жопу на десяток
ж ніг направ intel і пням р-н невський
французьких місць паркан похмурих Една пляж
жінка вікі наносять вирощують бачу
принципам моралі та секуляризму
а так вже провалом bespeco та охорони
здоров'я у четвер ось і буркіні вислала
вся та прем'єр-міністр України будь-який
любить hennessy мережу що руки не c
комбінація злив бікіні та бурка білка для
монет з символом мимоволі низинки
не б перебування зинка угра травневому
місії чому
непристойно так та так не врятувати [ __ ] it
and you dig і кипсале
протеза гурони закрита у купальника
вислав із мусульман та малюків українці я
з-за кордоном за крима і дизайнер до
завстра лика
ви знайшла буркіні один так не сандре
страждаю нас на правильно відразу милі за
алітус видно з нашим за будинком буркіні
moves приємної інтеграції
бімів об'єктного ти різанини культури дружина
кікі вигляд дають право в прибиранні її та tedx
the oberoi бікіні травня ніби свобода
вибору
за людина-то fairy of choice за словом
та дизайнер до петля за барони французької
владику патна буркіні лиж адреса вуса гір
зависим руки вахида зауважте продала в
жопу над 700 тисяч закритих купальники
причому у пана 40 особа таки у продаж за
її словами і пропадають на мусульман
вухо ножі ніг цим ніг видно закривати
вушка руна пляжів на прокат за в газетну
лікаря тим приватним мусульман з Франції
безодні частина шукаєте по чому ти на пляжах
сусідню італію а джейд алейська влада
вийшов
на паркан уніати ринком зараз магату і
купатися біля закритого озера